The Joe Rogan Experience and this is the
same guy that just passed this [ __ ]
law in New York City where you have to
have a vaccine passport to go everywhere
you have to have a vaccine to go to a
restaurant to a gym to any place where
people gather it is crazy and meanwhile
the vast person the the biggest
percentage of people that don't have
vaccines or have been vaccinated are
people of color
so this guy people of color and
immigrants this is what he's always
supposed to be Pro you know Pro people
of color Pro diversity pro-immigration
those are the people that don't have
vaccines and now you're precluding them
from going to gyms and restaurants and
what about the people working in the
restaurants what about all these
it's [ __ ] Madness and then you have a
bunch of people that are supporting it
like yay finally meanwhile you have
science is coming out there's legitimate
articles Jamie I'll send this to you now
there's legitimate art because doctors
have been sending me these things and
you know this is neither Pro nor con
vaccine I'm not this is not a judgment
statement but imperfect vaccination can
enhance the transmission of Highly
virulent pathogens right so this is a
scientific paper
um from 2015.
that shows
that
if here's this is one important quote
vaccines that keep the host alive but
still allow transmission can thus allow
virulent strains to circulate in a
population so
vaccines that don't kill the virus
vaccines that allow people like this is
one of the things we're finding out
about what they're calling breakthrough
cases right so people who are vaccinated
can still get covid and they can still
transmit covert this recently happened
at The Comedy Store a vaccinated
comedian gave covid to like 12 different
[ __ ] people at the comedy store some
of them vaccinated some of them not
that situation where the vaccine just
kind of protects you from serious damage
right but it protects you from really
being like badly hospitalized or deaf
but doesn't stop you from getting the
virus can possibly lead to more potent
viruses so these people that are saying
oh it's these unvaccinated people that
are responsible for the variance well
there's actually scientific papers that
point to the very sort of environment
that we're creating by having so many
people vaccinated with a vaccine that
doesn't kill off the virus it actually
can lead to more potent viruses
try finding that story anywhere
other than doctors I'm getting PhD
sending me these things guys who won't
speak about it publicly because they're
worried about the blowback
people who are Physicians people who are
even even epidemiologists even people
that deal with diseases and viruses
they're concerned and they don't want to
talk about it publicly because people
call them anti-vaxxers oh yes it's
really wild out there well it's wild
because they've somehow managed and when
I say they meaning the political Elite
and then I think their established media
Representatives have somehow managed to
turn this into a political issue right
and
that's dangerous right it's dangerous
for any politician to play in that game
where they're using something as
meaningful and quite possibly dangerous
for the country as political posturing
or virtue signaling right and you see it
all the time because you see these guys
are wearing their masks for the camera
but then they take them off they also
just got busted doing that yesterday you
see the video yeah we had no mask on
hanging out with everybody and then they
could take a picture she puts the mask
on and then takes it off after the
picture's done yeah or they can have
parties you know what is it uh you know
how about Obama yeah Obama's having that
700 guest party or whatever
yeah because of because of the pandemic
yeah make it a little lighter but you
can't go to a gym in New York right
unless you have a vaccination card where
you can't go out to eat uh we're gonna
shut down small businesses you can't go
to a comedy club uh and I think it's
it's rules for thee and not for me
scenario and people read right through
through that [ __ ] because some people I
think even plotting it which is [ __ ]
terrifying I know smart people that are
applauding it it's so strange and the
the problem with applauding vaccine
passports
this is this is part of the problem
they are not going to give that power up
no they're not going to they're going to
find a reason to continue to use that if
they can figure out a way to force you
into carrying papers into carrying
something that lets you enter businesses
or lets you do this or lets businesses
open as soon as you give politicians
power
in any kind of power that didn't exist
previously historically they don't
relinquish that power they find new
reasons to use it well I think that's
the history of law making and political
power in the United States and I think
that's why I I tend to be bucketed in
conservatives because it means smaller
government to me right there's there's
multiple reasons why people classify
themselves as that uh
but
I look at things and I look at the
preservation of individual liberty you
know how do I preserve more of my
freedom because I feel like I'm in a
responsible adult and I feel like I'm
going to raise responsible adults and I
feel like I spend most of my time around
responsible adults
all right
I don't it's such a a disconnect in uh
individual philosophy when I find people
that
that are actively looking for ways that
they can forfeit their individual
liberty and hand it over to somebody
where they feel like they have a better
interest in running their life than they
do right I understand the balance
between uh you know we we have to have
certain laws and regulations that that
protect people against you know overt
dangers but I also understand your
statement where I think politicians and
I would say lawmakers and uh government
bureaucrats have a really hard time
relinquishing control once they have it
it makes their jobs good yeah makes
their job easier they can just tell you
to shut the [ __ ] up do what I say and
you have to you know you can't work
anymore unless you do what I say that's
essentially what a vaccine passport is
right you can't do what you want to do
unless you do what I want you to do
I mean Don Lemon was talking about that
openly on CNN yeah don't have a vaccine
can't go to the supermarket don't have a
vaccine can't go to work
like it's so strange that people want to
say things like that like that's the
thing that blows me away why do you why
do people want to because they're dumb
they're dumb they're dumb they don't
understand history they don't understand
human beings they don't understand human
nature they don't understand the history
of every single country that's ever
existed other than the United States up
until 1776 every [ __ ] country that
has ever existed was run by dictators
right all of them this is the first one
where you had elected officials this is
the first experiment in self-government
that actually worked and he created the
greatest superpower in the world's ever
known it created the greatest cultural
machine the greatest machine of Art and
creativity and Innovation right [ __ ]
here and how did it do that it did it
through freedom because when you give
people Freedom you let people do
whatever the [ __ ] they want to do they
actually find ways to succeed and grow
and Thrive but as soon as you put the
boots to them as soon as you tell them
you have to do this or you can't do that
you have to listen to me now you have a
mini dictator you have one step away
from a king you have a one step closer
you're moving one step closer to
dictatorship that's what the [ __ ] is
happening that's what's going to happen
with a vaccine passport that's what's
going to happen if they close borders
you can't enter New York City unless you
have your papers you can't go to here
unless you have that you can't get on a
plane unless you do what I say and
people say whoa It's all about
protecting people from them no it's not
it's not because we've shown this is a
fact just a couple of months ago the
idea of a breakthrough case was unheard
of nobody heard of anybody catching
covid that had a vaccine right that was
the whole idea you get a vaccine you
have to worry about it now we know not
only do you get it but you can spread it
and some people have died apparently
it's a small number I don't know what
the numbers are but I know that most
people who get vaccinated when they do
have the disease they have a better time
of it than the people who are
unvaccinated
but where are the people out there
calling for people to get healthy where
are the people out there calling for
people to lose weight 78 of the people
in the ICU for covid are obese 78 where
is that information being shared where's
someone who's a leader who gets on TV
and says ladies and gentlemen we've got
to decrease our body mass we've got to
decrease our fat we've got to make sure
that people aren't overweight we got to
make sure that people are healthy walk
around your block you don't have to do
something complicated start drinking
more water stop eating sugar start
taking vitamins you can increase the
strength of your immune system we can
fight things off better we can be a
healthier civilization better for
everybody right you want to hear a peep
all you hear is take this vaccine that
doesn't even prevent you from getting
the disease or you can't go to this to
the sauna or wherever the [ __ ] you want
to go you can't go to the Broadway show
it's Madness it's Madness it really is
madness because if it was a vaccine that
really is like a like here's a like it's
more of a treatment than it is a vaccine
really if you look at it because you're
saying you need a booster now every six
months look if you get vaccinated for
polio you get vaccinated for the measles
you don't have to worry about it anymore
you're good this is not that this is a
totally different kind of thing and it's
a completely new kind of vaccine the
idea that people shouldn't be skeptical
or nervous about that is kind of
hilarious
well it's kind of hilarious that people
won't try on skepticism in general like
they need to be more skeptical they need
to push people in Authority in power and
hold them accountable for their words
and their actions
and there's this reluctancy I think
across the board to question power
either on both sides right so it's like
the blue likes to question red red likes
to question but now you'll follow
lockstep in party line if one is saying
something or the other
that's a [ __ ] problem to to your
point I was reading uh
I was reading the the history of the Nez
Perce Indian tribe and I've read a few
books on this just recently I'm from
northern Idaho where where the Nez Perce
Indian tribe ferocious people amazing
like amazing Warriors Chief Joseph was
an incredible leader uh incredible
history
but it struck me there there's a there's
one chapter in the books that I was
reading about how the U.S uh Cavalry
they were putting the Native Americans
on reservations for their protection and
I'm not trying to equate this in direct
correlation but this was part of the
narrative because they were saying we
want to put you guys on reservations to
protect you from the settlers
and from uh retaliation so we want to
put you guys on this you know 400 square
reservation 400 Mile Square reservation
for your protection and they're like
dude
we want to be free I don't know what
you're talking about
and uh they go in and and they trace the
over a thousand miles that Chief Joseph
LED his his uh his tribe through Idaho
and Montana and then up close to the uh
the Canadian border but I couldn't help
but think about
there's one sliver of history in the
late 1800s which in 1873 I believe it
was which was also connected to the the
son of uh Meriwether Lewis was also part
of the the Nez parsinian tribe because
he had a son there but I thought about
how
us not us as a country how we need to be
pushed to ask more questions and we
deserve more answers we have to hold
skepticism I think in a very high regard
and we can't beat it down I think
any time that you question authority
it's a good thing especially as a
society because it also says that you
have a healthy Society if you have this
complex narrative you know moving up
from underneath I think the the
Groundswell of information from people
you can have these complex discussions
but you also have to have very good
answers to what's going on I think
you've got conflicting information
that's being politicized and it's being
gaslit by both sides of the media which
I don't blame people for being pissed
off and confused because
man I'm confused yeah like this is
confusing as [ __ ] the CDC releases
something the president will say
something else some random Governor
somewhere that I've never heard of will
say something else you're like
what the hell is going on what is going
on yeah that's that's why I listened to
uh Crystal and Sagar because they yeah
typically know what well they typically
know what's going on and they're they're
a great example because that show
Breaking points you got Sagar who's on
the right and Crystal who's on the left
but they're good friends they get along
well and they're both super honest and
objective rational and intelligent and
they can discuss all the finer points of
these issues honestly openly and it's
that's why they're thriving it's why CNN
like some of their shows they're they're
some of their shows are they get a
hundred thousand views in the key
demographic less than a hundred thousand
even that's crazy since Trump is out of
office oh yeah and they don't have a
boogeyman yeah their boogeyman is on
vaccinated people that's what they're
doing their boogeyman is different
different things they can attack watch
the entire episode for free only on
Spotify